one of the most interesting and really
innovative aspects of this this work the
consolation of philosophy in boethius's
analysis about goods and the nature of
happiness is not only that he shows that
that these don't really satisfy the way
that we often take them to and we're not
thinking as clearly as we want to but
then he takes the problem and pulls it
deeper and deeper into what has genuine
being what is going to ultimately be a
kind of unity and that casts a light
backwards onto all these other goods so
that we can put them into proper
perspective so where we're going from
this this big question mark over here is
ultimately going to be I'm going to let
you in on the secret right now it's
ultimately going to be God but God in
understood in a philosophical way as
something that we can not only
acknowledge or you know pray to or but
also participate in something that we
can be like by having the right
orientation by trying to cultivate
virtue that is going to put all these
other things into the right perspective
but we this doesn't deny actually that
these are in fact to some degree goods
they're just not stable goods they're
not the kinds of goods that we should
ultimately be resting everything on how
are we going to get there well we want
to see how this actually goes you notice
that I've got this word means up there
and then in parentheses ends so what are
we talking about ends and means what we
really mean are what means do we need to
get to our ends what do i what do we
identify as the ends the goals the
purposes the values that we are striving
after so boys this is going to look at
each one of these in turn and ask is it
the good we've already seen him view
some of that
and now he wants to make it a little bit
more encompassing more universal global
he's asking about what is it we're
really after with these things and if we
pay attention to individual people or we
look at classes of people some people
actually do desire wealth that seems to
be their fundamental motivation we can
ask about them what are they really
doing what are they after and we notice
that the answer was what they really
want to self-sufficiency and the main
problem with wealth is that it can't
really provide us with self sufficiency
we saw that if you want to be wealthy
you have to do a lot of things and you
have to make a lot of sacrifices and
then even after you have the wealth you
got to keep spending more wealth just to
hold on to the wealth that you have and
it doesn't you know take care of fear it
doesn't take care of the fact that
you're going to die someday it's the
same thing with power power actually
depends on you know a sort of
powerlessness of other people and
perhaps even you know replicates it
within yourself and it can't ultimately
satisfy Fame same thing in this this
section in book 3 he's also gonna
consider fret pleasure and friendship I
almost said fresher I suppose maybe when
you have pleasure and friendship both
rolled together make up a new word and
here's what's really interesting we can
look at these in a number of different
ways we can say that for any given
person these are their their ends this
is what they value most this is what
they will sacrifice for and then we're
treating each one of these is an end but
we can also say yeah but why are they
why why is this guy want to heap up all
this money why is that person going
after political office what do they want
to get out of it and boëthius knows that
there can be a sort of confusion and a
cycling around throughout all of this
because we might want wealth in order to
be famous or we might want wealth in
order to buy friends we might want
wealth in order to buy things that we
find pleasure in you know it could be
anything from you know collecting stamps
to using hard drugs and everything in
between right
we similarly we might want power some
people want to see power just so they
can use it to make a ton of money
other people want power so that they can
become famous other people want power so
that they can help out their friends and
we could go through each of these any of
them can become a means or an end for
the other one that should show us
something there this is these are
shifting sands these are not things that
are completely stable and we see what
the dynamics are with wealth and power
and fame let's look at what he actually
has to say about about friendship
Louisiana says that there's no support
and friends that you acquire because of
your good fortune rather than your
personal qualities so if you're buying
your friends or you've got your friends
because of power or people are hanging
out with you is sort of an entourage
because you're famous or because you're
supplying them with pleasure watch out
when you lose those Goods of fortune
because those friends are going to
disappear they're not going to be your
friends forever and if you haven't
cultivated the kinds of good qualities
that you actually need in order to be a
good friend in order to be somebody who
other people would want to be with for
their own sake then that friendship is
not going to be something very stable
either it's not going to be something
that can provide you with security it's
a matter of fact you know there's all
sorts of stories about people that we
call false friends what about pleasure
he says a bodily pleasure there's really
nothing to say its pursuit is full of
anxiety and its fulfillment full of
remorse so let's let's actually think
about that for a minute though bodily
pleasure is full of remorse and the
pursuit is full of anxiety what are the
sorts of things that he's talking about
what are the things that we take bodily
pleasure we like to eat eating involves
not only you know filling up the belly
when we're hungry
but we like the taste of things as well
we like to drink drink things
coffee tea coke I like beer wine what
else
the people enjoy well the beer and wine
is a good example I suppose actually the
coffee tea and Coca's are great examples
too is that's you know caffeine so
there's a stimulant we like the effects
that certain things have on us besides
just the taste we like the charge that
we get from the caffeine
we like the perhaps excitement or the
mellowness that alcohol initially
stimulating effect and a sort of opening
effect is great for brainstorming they
say afterwards a depressing effect
people like other things as well those
are all bodily pleasures what else do we
enjoy we like laying around and sleeping
in and sunbathing and you know floating
in the pool sitting in the hot tub those
are those are nice things massages those
are all sort of in the realm of comfort
we enjoy sexual pleasure as well
unless you're a hedonic which you know
is a actually you know just order to
state you enjoy that sort of thing you
know we could multiply things we enjoy
engaging in sports you know in
activities where we're moving our bodies
around that feeling of motion is
something we like some people like
getting on rollercoasters and getting
getting scared right or going to haunted
houses that that's in a certain sense of
bodily pleasure so we can talk about all
sorts of examples like this now is their
pursuit full of anxiety it really
depends on the kinds of pleasures that
we're seeking certainly you're probably
gonna have to give up some wealth in
order to get many pleasures in today's
economy aren't you and some of them
could be full of remorse
let's take sexual pleasure for it for an
example are their you know if you had no
restrictions whatsoever on how to attain
sexual pleasure if society didn't care
about how you did it if you didn't feel
any sort of sense of shame about what
you did then I suppose there wouldn't be
any remorse now would there it's
interesting because there's a
philosopher a cynic Diogenes who was
caught getting off to the marketplace
and his response to all the people who
are saying what a degenerate you are was
if only a me could rub my belly in and
make
go away so easily but most people aren't
like that are they most of us have some
sense of propriety and there's certain
limits and it could be tempting to cross
those limits that some people get in
trouble isn't it I know I shouldn't
flirt with this person over here but it
makes me feel good that's making them
feel good too
and then somebody finds your text
messages right who is this person
now suddenly there's all sorts of
problems doing that that pursuing that
pleasure didn't actually provide you
with some sort of stable go ahead you
could say it may actually result in the
loss of these sorts of things great
examples all sorts of things again if we
want to talk about sexual pleasure
recent cases Anthony Weiner Eliot
Spitzer losing power Brett Favre Fame is
tarnished because of his sexting
scandals people pay out money to to
blackmailers and we can go on and on
with all sorts of other pleasures if
you're a glutton you have to spend a lot
of money if you you know become addicted
to drugs all these things can can get
lost
can't they so pleasure can be
problematic it can't provide us with the
happiness that we want but we this goes
a little further though and he says if
bodily pleasure can give us happiness
there's no need to deny that animals are
totally happy because all they really do
is seek out the fulfillment of their
bodily needs
he says the pleasures some pleasures are
actually what he calls honest pleasures
that means pleasures that we indulge in
and they're the kinds of pleasures that
we want to pursue the plungers derived
from a wife and children are examples of
that but there's a story all too natural
that a certain man found his children
tormenters so you know the things that
we originally think are going to give us
pleasure may turn out not to give us
pleasure so over here we have all these
sorts of things they are genuine goods
what is it that we're after are we
you know using one of these to get
another one of these or you just
exchanging them for each other
or is there something bigger is there a
a a more fundamental need that we human
beings are trying to satisfy with you
thinks there is and he's talked about in
terms of self-sufficiency
he has also talked about it in terms of
satisfaction of desire a state of
self-sufficiency would be a state in
which we're actually satisfied we are
content because we've had what we need
and we've got more of it if we need it
we have a secure possession of the good
none of these things can actually
provide us with that but in every one of
them this is what we're seeking and what
are we really seeking what does this
really comprise that's really about this
conception of happiness now you might
say to yourself well happiness it's
super-easy to get you just go and get a
chocolate bar or a balloon or listen to
a song you know say the happy song
alright that will help you but that's
not what he means by happiness and when
we're talking about happiness in a
philosophical sense we mean something
more than just a momentary state we mean
a way of being the greek word for that
was a eudaimonia the Latin word is
beyond a tudo we get the Beatitudes from
that and the notion is that if you're
really happy it's something that is
going to go on for a long time it's
going to be uninterrupted it's going to
be something that actually is secure
once you're truly happy it's not
something that can be easily taken away
from you
now that puts things in a different
perspective doesn't if we say when we're
looking for these things what we really
want is happiness what we really want is
something like this and that's how we
understand happiness but here we get to
a key a key point what do we think
happiness is do we do
you have just sort of a rosy imagination
of it we've never really given it much
thought
we're just so busy going after this sort
of stuff we're just trying to keep our
head above water then we never worry
about what we're actually aiming for
what we're trying to attain we probably
should think about this there should
come a time during every person's life
where they say am I really happy what
would it take to make me happy what the
hell isn't to be happy I'm not even
quite sure and you know if you don't do
this sooner or later you will actually
have crises during your life often times
these happen at the midpoint which is
why they're called midlife crises but
some people have them in their 20s some
people have them in their 30s other
people continue to have them throughout
their life and they want to know what is
actually going to make me happy what
will fulfill me what will be a
meaningful existence and you can try to
shove as much of this stuff into that
question into the hole opened up by that
question and it may not fill it up you
can buy it as much stuff as you like
retail therapy
you're gonna choir absolute power over
other people you can become famous you
can become a celebrity and still not
actually be happy so the issue is what
conceptions of happiness do we actually
have do we have false conceptions of
what it is to be happy we theists
doesn't worry about it in this respect
but one thing that we probably ought to
think about in the 21st century is are
we getting fed false ideas about what
happiness is through advertising through
our culture through other people that
surround us who have got themselves
mixed up with these sorts of things and
would like to see us as mixed up as them
those are valid concerns what would be
the true conception of happiness here we
actually have to do a bit of thinking
that's a question mark and what if we
want to fill this in we have to work our
way towards it so what belief this is
going to do
is he's going to try to think about what
might actually make us truly happy and
he says what would it be what would we
need to have he says all of these roads
to happiness are side tracks things like
wealth pleasure the satisfaction of
desires for power for even some desires
for security they cannot bring us to the
destination they promised why because
they also bring along other problems you
know for example if you if you want to
hoard money you have to take it by force
if you want to have high office you have
to grovel before people and kiss a lot
of the rear end as they say in order to
get the power that you want well what
would be truly happiness then he says
self-sufficiency is part of that and now
he's talking back and forth with
philosophy and she says if there were
thing that were self-sufficient able to
accomplish what it wants from its own
resources glorious
worthy rat rats surely that being would
be supremely happy let's think about
this for a moment what's she saying
there what the person who wanted wealth
and power wanted was to be
self-sufficient not even self-sufficient
as far as spelling goes to be able to
accomplish everything from their own
resources to actually be famous but to
be rightly famous to be famous for the
right reasons and here's where it gets
really interesting philosophy tells us
that this is a unity a oneness all of
these things are actually the same
because they're all combined in one
thing she goes on to say human
perversity human mistakes makes
divisions of that which by nature is one
and simple
and each one tries to grab a separate
part of it and when they do that the
parts don't add up to the whole so going
after wealth for example or going after
power this being would in fact have
power but the power that this being has
is part of you know what it is is not
the same thing as power in isolation
power in isolation is less powerful than
the power that this being this unity has
so she goes on and she says it's
impossible to find happiness among these
things which are thought to confer each
of the desired States individually like
wealth power Fame all those sorts of
things so
what is this done Boethius says even a
blind person could see it and you reveal
that when you're trying to show the
causes of false happiness unless I'm
mistaken true and perfect happiness is
that which makes a person self
sufficient strong worthy of respect
glorious enjoyable so we got to add a
few other things here strong joyful all
of these comprise a unity now that's a
hard thing to find isn't it what being
would there be
that's totally self sufficient able to
accomplish whatever it accomplishes from
its own resources glorious worthy of
reverence straw joyful what could that
be well you know for boëthius this is
actually going to be God God is a unity
of all of these things God or the divine
and he says human goods are only shadows
of the true good are in perfect
blessings and they cannot confer and
perfect good so what is this then may
they actually have a interesting passage
in one of the things of praying so the
the question that he turns to that and
this is still in book three this is in
Chapter ten is where are we going to
find this well why is this going to be
God because we can't conceive of
anything that is superior that is
greater than God because God is this
this is what it is
to be great and to be supremely great
just to pass all of the things now that
raises some problems for us doesn't it
if we're all about our happiness and God
enjoys this and God has all this stuff
that's great
god how does that help us how does that
give us any of what we actually need as
human beings well if we go on and we
look at this a little bit further the
question then is how can we let me put
it on board how can a human enjoy the
happiness of God that's a really valid
question human beings are imperfect
we've already see them we're all screwed
up when it comes to the nature of what
is happiness we make stupid mistakes our
culture's our societies teach us
mistaken viewpoints on what happiness is
we subject ourselves to these Goods of
fortune when there's really only one
thing that is actually enjoying
happiness how do we make that our own
how do we come to enjoy happiness well
if she says everything that's good is so
through participation and goodness so
enjoyment comes through participation so
it's not like enjoying God would be like
enjoying a candy bar where you consume
it and it becomes you know part of you
you've dominated it becomes your thing
and you wouldn't be able to enjoy God by
just imagining God is this tyrant up in
the sky who gives all these rules and
regulations I'm just gonna keep my head
down and follow them
that's not very enjoyable either is it
no we participate in the good somehow
and this is part of what has to be
clarified so how would they happen
she goes on yes she she's talking about
different things animate and inanimate
how do we rise to the level of the
divine
she says all things seek the good and
you could describe that by calling it
saying that goodness itself is that
which all things desire what is that for
us that ultimately this is where it's
going to get very interesting the only
way that a human being can truly enjoy
the happiness that God not only enjoys
but is is by participating more and more
in that divine being and that's going to
be a process of becoming like God the
Greek word for this is theosis meaning
God becoming organizing if you want to
call it that now what would that
actually mean for us human beings this
is the last thing that we need to think
about with respect to this this
particular set of goods does it mean
that we would become in fact
self-sufficient should we try to be like
God by mastering everything that we come
across perhaps through technology
perhaps through becoming a tyrant and
dominating everybody else well that's
not how God does it God is connecting
all these unities together we just saw
that going after power by its own sea is
not actually going to make us happy and
it's actually self-defeating in the
process how could we be like God well
what could we cultivate that would do
that
this process of theosis depends on human
beings developing the virtues that also
means that human beings have to get away
from them Isis
various forms of badness that we have
you know if we're intemperate if we're
greedy if we're foolish and the more
that we acquire virtue the more that we
have a good that actually is stable that
can be part of this unity that can help
us to understand all those other goods
and how those goods of fortune could be
properly used so we've gone a long ways
we've gone from these other goods
through what we're really after with
those two a proposal about what it is
that happiness really consists in namely
the divine and we come back to what does
that mean for us human beings that we
need to focus on virtue as that which
actually is our good and that will then
cast light on how we want to understand
all these other goods that other people
seem to think are the be-all and end-all